speed of light squared so matter like
this table was actually light but it's
frozen light right so and the same thing
like what water is to ice
energy is to matter it's kind of the
analogy right and Joseph Campbell was
this famous American mythologist he said
he thought that energy and consciousness
were the same thing so I kind of think
everything's conscious like the whole
universe is alive just we're more alive
or like a higher frequency of
consciousness whereas this table has it
has a really low frequency I have
nothing to back that up by the way it
just sort of things that I've tied
together so to say aliens I mean like us
almost certainly they're out there
mathematically but I think consciousness
is ubiquitous I don't think I've ever
expected somebody to say that the table
has a conscious that's a fantastic
all right well one question you have for
me to finish up what worries or scares
you about this transition I mean it's
clearly it's major so what do you see
the people who can be best helped will
miss it and the reason
twofold one it is a parachute that is
masked as an adrenaline rush okay I like
that meaning that the escape hatch that
the thing that can save you from the
existing system is being promoted by
many as because right so if you think
it's like you jump out of a plane
there's some people who do it for the
adrenaline rush and then there's some
people who are just super thankful I got
a parachute yeah right because I fell
out it's really hard to get somebody who
doesn't like adrenaline rushes to go
jump out of a plane right and until the
planes crashing right all of a sudden
everyone wants to parachute yeah right
so there's a little bit of that going on
yeah the second piece is we have done
such a poor job not only the Unites
States across the world a financial
education that even people who
understand even people who believe this
has value and can be important fear wins
the day and so a man you know what I
tell people all the time is I can't tell
you what to do in your personal
situation I don't have all the facts
wrong information I don't know your
goals are no shop sizing for etc but
what I can tell you is being right and
not reaping the benefits is almost as
bad if not worse than being wrong so if
you're the person who makes fifty
thousand dollars a year you've got
twenty thousand dollars in savings
you've got
you know bills you got to pay you got a
family etc and you buy $10 worth of
Bitcoin because you believe that's the
future mm-hmm and you are right that $10
will have no impact and so again what
ends up happening is what is the risk
tolerance that somebody has right how do
they think about portfolio management
how do they think about when to take
risk off the table in some situations
how do they think about the other things
they're doing in their portfolio which
may reduce the overall risk right how do
you think of an encore like all of these
things are actually highly complex
topics that even some of the best
professional money managers or financial
advisors in the world get wrong mm-hmm
if you are an individual the likelihood
that you can kind of line up multiple
decisions so I got to do my work or my
own research I got to understand what
this is I then got to believe it is
gonna be important and valuable I think
got a sized it correctly my portfolio
for the upside and the downside though I
got to have the intestinal fortitude
courage persistence and frankly naivety
to not be emotional and biased when the
volatility happens and then at some
point I've got to be able to navigate
the security the the announcements from
different governments and organizations
and almost like you start overlaying all
the stuff to end up at the end having
been right with the right size you know
not completely unwavering etc it's gonna
be a small number of people and yeah
that's why it's important to stay humble
on stack sets look Marty is gonna come
in here in a little bit and I think that
him and Matt Odell got the right idea
man that is that is the meme by the way
for a Bitcoin I tend to think again
you know I say it over and over again on
the podcast like people have to do their
own research they have to understand
there's a lot of risk in this but on the
chance that any of this is correct
we are talking about something that we
can't comprehend today that's right
right and what I always describe to
people is when the iPhone was created 12
years ago we're not talking about a long
time ago I think it's 13 years now right
so 2007 who in their right mind thought
ah podcast an uber yeah yeah all right
right podcast nuber are gonna be a thing
yeah nobody there
but that is part of the impact of the
iPhone yes the Internet today literally
there are people watching a live stream
right now of us having this conversation
crazy who would have thought that 30
years ago yeah nobody and so it's just
like we not only overestimate what we
can do in one year and underestimate 10
but you know the gates quote but I
actually think that over like a 20 30
year period on day one we can't even
imagine we couldn't even dream of what's
possible for really really innovative -
from the technology the question comes
down to is Bitcoin gonna be one of those
or as Bitcoin gonna go the way of all of
the other things that we're gonna be
great it ended up not being it's like as
the rate of change gets faster we get
more blind to what the future holds
almost yeah it's so fast
well back to we can't understand
compounding we doesn't understand
exponential growth all right that's what
the digital age is all about it's being
built on top of the Internet yeah all
right man where can people find you on
the Internet
so I'm at a Twitter at breedlove 22
which is my last name as BR ee d l.o.v.e
22 where the 22 come from it's just one
of my favorite numbers and they tell me
some crazy stories high school sports
about a conscious table or something
yeah I post there about a lot of my
writings and our website is parallax
digital i/o PA are a double LAX digital
i/o
awesome n thank you for coming to do
this thanks man there's a lot of fun I
think that people are gonna like this I
hope they do we're gonna see